direct revenge
again the again marzipan cat
watch najaf an Indian can build
so directly to exchange the runner
the attempt succeeded
so that's that because now I have
a kind of mini
without the runner I
can of course take the shop but
it's questionable  if that brings so much
ok
yes but I won't
do it here we'll do it again to be on the
safe side but also Hafenstadt g5
I really want to play the four
weakens for that first
properly
so
maybe you can do
h5 right away and nibble on
g5  I just springer h5
and then he can also do a few six
schools so it doesn't matter much
so now that's
fine okay
now of course he has
completely ruined his structure in the hope that he can
still get an attack going,
well  now he can make five that
I would maybe be better played differently
I don't know exactly how
bad it is now ir  kinda
not for black but
actually you had to get a little
something out of the position
that you can't necessarily
say here that we succeeded
copper pass king makes bring
then i thought jump four
actually in the 55
yeah
that's kinda right of course
yeah  of course we
played it
god will i go
really big attack shame
easy thomas seven of course also
play for jumps helped
35 through
although wait a minute for a spin on 3.7
king 46 even if it looks totally
insane jumper five
jumper simply i  1
time bidding
doesn't matter
man oh man
check
well I'm definitely somehow now
it doesn't matter or
see anything but
we have f2 somehow adam f 2 or
prospective afghan talks
had seen it that way we have three years
namely that one purpose
26 well maybe works  it also
somehow still
looks terrible, of course,
I have
no idea  see nothing
yes i actually survived i think
chem chem
da jumper so that you with
what madness yes
no idea